it's time now for a special Cyber Monday
edition of CBS morning's deals and this
morning we're bringing back five of our
most popular deals to start shopping
scan the QR code on your screen right
now or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle
expert Elizabeth Warner joins us right
now good morning good morning oh my
goodness it's so great to be here and I
have to tell you we worked really hard
to pull these items together okay for
Cyber Monday pricing
feel that warm this is called calming
Heat this is not your mom you just hit
the massager hello so there's heat in
here there's a massage feature you can
pick the levels of massage the levels of
heat and if you put your hand under it
it's actually weighted it's got clay
beads inside so it feels like a hug it's
soothing it's relaxing it's the perfect
gift so you're talking breast recovery
anything that's what athletes after a
long day right that's exactly right yes
okay so what do we do we're all gonna
love that so right now that's 40 off it
is
38.99 talk to me okay gift of luxury yes
yes all right so this is the Kelvin 33
this is an amazing versatile tool this
was one of my favorites look at this
right so 16 different bits we've got the
LED light so when we work we can
actually see what we're doing there is
the tape measure what and a level on
this so you think of like the DIY people
the fix it people may maybe somebody
going for the first time to an apartment
you need tools you know what I love
about this I'm always at home like honey
where's the toolbox by the time I get
the toolbox I never can find what I'm
looking for it does everything you've
got your Hammer like you saw all of that
it's small fits right in your hand this
is going to go with you everywhere yes
so this one is 40 off it's down to 29.99
yeah it's kind of stocking look my
husband's hard to buy for that fits in a
stocking and he's gonna love that all
right yes all right so jump smart now
this is amazing this is an item that
actually can jump start your car it
looks like a flashlight it does have
lights built in would you like to hold
it here yeah for sure and in addition in
addition they do include the jumper
cables you no longer need a stranger to
help you you're not going to be stranded
anywhere you don't have to call for AAA
and then it also has dual yes USB ports
on it so we're going to be able to
charge all of our devices perfect for
anyone that you love that drives go
ahead wait yeah anyone you love stories
that's right and also perfect if you
know somebody who lives in an area that
they constantly lose power this is a
really amazing gift I don't let my kids
drive in the car without it and just
like it's Compact and convenient that's
right exactly so keep it in the car all
right so right now 31 off down to
95.99 Cyber Monday pricing these things
are going to fly okay Tiki Tunes
remember how much fun you and I had with
these ready wait hey hey Christmas give
me another shot of egg all right
this these are tiki torches these are
going to make your holiday parties
amazing you'll see the Ambiance it looks
like an actual torch with the the lights
that are moving the speakers actually
can be paired together this fly that's
amazing for the person who has
everything they don't have this and they
will love it all ages all right so Tiki
Tunes buy one get one so you're getting
two for 49.99 oh that's a win-win okay
invis aware this is incredibly important
this is a device that you wear that's
actually for personal safety so on the
back of this if you click the charm
twice it will send five discrete SOS
messages out to your contacts that you
choose it could be your friends it could
be 9-1-1 so it will alert them and we
were just talking during the commercial
break yes it's personal for you this is
really personal for me right because
Beyond
um when you think about people walking
to work or college campuses if you have
a medical issue my daughter does if
anything ever happened she can push this
button which she has you got one of the
alerts I got one of the alerts
absolutely and actually it sends you in
that alert it sends you their geo
location so you know exactly where your
loved one is so if you are a jogger if
you have a health issue right it doesn't
matter where you are it looks beautiful
every age it's for every age I have a 12
year old baby girl that's right and this
it gives us parents peace of mind but
also the people who have issues price
amazing yeah so right now it is 30 off
174.30
it looks good too yeah it does it's a
little sparkly and fun right just like
you sparkly thank you Elizabeth Warner
we appreciate you so much of course we
partner with all of these companies to
get these deals to buy anything that you
saw scan the QR code on your screen
right now or you can head over to
cbsdeals.com and tomorrow Elizabeth
joins us once again with the bonus
edition of CBS mornings deals including
a Bluetooth karaoke machine you that
might just be the hit of your holiday
party and it's all available that one is
available at 30 off retail price that's
coming up tomorrow on CBS mornings we
will be right back